it's great to Welcome to the program
today Tess Wilkinson Ryan who's a moral
psychologist and a law professor at the
University of Pennsylvania and also
author of The recently released book
foolproof how fear of playing the sucker
shapes ourselves and the social order
and what we can do about it really great
having you on today I appreciate your
time thank you so much for
so much so to start with
maybe about what is the sucker construct
or or that idea that you talk about and
elaborate in the book
yeah the the soccer construct is the
idea that there are a whole bunch of
interactions or sort of Dynamics
transactions in our everyday lives that
take the shape or can take the shape of
a scam that feel like wait a minute I
have a concern here that I'm about to or
or I have I'm about to sort of
voluntarily enter into something that's
going to leave me holding the bag it's
going to leave me with some unfair bad
results thus making me a sucker and the
reason for thinking about this as a
construct is that it can sort of be
overlaid on a variety of situations it's
not odd always obvious that you have
like a Ponzi scheme going on
what sorts of situations that might not
be obvious right like outside of actual
Ponzi schemes would this be relevant
he says where you've gone to buy
something and the price is higher than
you thought it should be
um so I give an example in the book of
my sister going to buy a Gatorade from a
place that she really just realized when
she went in was a tourist trap and sort
of had this moment of being like you
know I'm not one of these people who
pays six dollars for Gatorade but she
was like actually really thirsty and
actually needed to get a gatorade ASAP
and she realized wait what am I doing
there's no reason for me to think I'm a
sucker here I just need to buy this
drink and move along other situations
that come up in everyday life would be
like um deciding whether or not to
believe somebody who's giving you an
excuse for something
um deciding whether to let someone cut
in front of you in traffic
um I think there's a lot of these little
Dynamics where people sort of get their
hackles up and think like what does it
make me if I let you you know whatever
Zoom down the breakdown lane and then
pop in front of me on the highway and
one of the arguments that you make and
that seems quite reasonable is that this
fear of being the sucker impacts
personal choices where if we had maybe a
more default belief that getting
suckered wasn't a possibility we would
behave differently than having this sort
of guard up what are the sorts of
personal choices that people would make
based on this fear of being suckered
sides of the yeah
I think about this as impacting
decisions that about that are about like
getting ahead and then impacting
decisions that are more like other
regarding so how you sort of do good
rather than yeah sort of how you be good
in the world I guess so one example
would be say personal investing so
um there's actually a really nice study
that sort of asks people
um that asks people in two different
conditions of an experiment how much
money would you invest in this company
if I gave you the stats of this company
and the stats of the company are either
look there's an 80 chance that investors
Break Even 15 chance that investors
double their money or a five percent
chance that they lose it all
and the five percent chance was this was
described to half the subject as a five
percent chance that the founders of the
company
um didn't they had underestimated sorry
they'd overestimated consumer demand
they made a mistake honest mistake
honest mistake exactly yeah so you can
see where it's going right so the other
half of the subjects are told there's a
five percent that five percent chance
that that five percent downside risk
that's the risk of these guys are frauds
um
and you know the numbers there are the
same
in right in both cases is a 95 chance of
breaking even or doing better than
breaking even but people had really
different responses to what to do in
those situations people were way less
willing to invest in the matey fraud
situation even though only a five
percent risk I guess the difference if
you wanted to argue that there is some
logic to that difference would be well
if they are frauds then we're definitely
not getting our return whereas if
they're wrong we might just get a
different return or market conditions
might change or I mean I get like it's
set up in a way where you're trying to
eliminate that but there there would be
some argument like that I guess no and I
think that that what you're describing
is actually exactly how this works
psychologically like I think you are
you're exactly right to think that the
way it works is that once you invoke the
fraud possibility people basically have
a whole bunch of ways that that sort of
fraud reasoning
affects the way they think about the
numbers right they think well the fraud
number is really bad that one's serious
the other number doesn't feel as serious
right the kinds of reasons that you
describe and you can think about the
ideas like how how prone are people to
fighting the hypo right they're sort of
like what's happening in the is that
you're sort of resisting the math which
is I think exactly what people are doing
in in the real world saying well wait
the math doesn't feel as bad to me right
and part of the argument is like that's
exactly that's exactly the point the
math feels worse once you invoke the
possibility of a scam rather than just a
mistake yeah that's an interesting one
what was the other example from a
different area
yeah the other example is I think that
um people that a lot of people find
pretty intuitive is that people can get
really
um nervous or wary about feeling like a
sucker when they start to get in when
they're engaging in basically like a
charitable transaction
so if you've ever heard of if you've
ever heard people
um sort of resisting donating money or
resisting even giving money to somebody
who's asking for money in on the street
for example and they say what are they
going to spend it on right and there's a
sort of what does it make me if they're
going to spend this money on something
that I don't approve of right that's
that's sort of a consistent fear
um and there's a whole bunch of
um sort of
asked me a while so there's a whole
bunch of please for example from
um food banks yes
and the food banks say we we really
appreciate donations but please donate
cash
cash is what we need because we know
what the needs are of the people who are
serving we don't pay retail prices right
we pay wholesale prices
um and we can
um and and we can um buy things in bulk
and a lot of people really resist
donating cash
it's a lot easier I think to raise to um
to do a charity drive where you're
asking for in-kind donations you know
toys coats food cans of of you know
canned goods rather than cash and
there's some really interesting studies
that suggest that people basically feel
like well cash is so easy to abuse cash
is going to you know if I give cash I'd
be worried what people are going to do
with it whereas if I give a can of
beans
there's only so many things you can do
with that yeah exactly it's kind of
exploitation proof right yeah yeah yeah
um
right so it's sort of exploitation proof
and
I know it I I can see how people can
sort of justify that in their minds like
what's going on there
but actually for any individual if I was
gonna donate let's take say food to a
food drive for me to take to get into my
car right and drive to a store and pay
retail prices for a bunch of rice and
beans and then to bring them to the food
bank is actually a huge waste of time
and money and for all I know they need
baby formula right not rice and beans
and so it's actually a way of making
this donation way less valuable and way
less and way more costly for me when it
comes to um I mean we're sort of kind of
getting into some stereotyping of like
what would the folks who are on the
receiving end be likely to do if they
received a versus B can you talk a
little more generally about how
stereotyping plays a role in the sucker
construct
yeah I think
I think appreciated
actually maybe I want to flip the
question a little bit and argue that
the ideas we have and the fears we have
about playing the sucker are actually
constitutive of a lot of Intergroup
stereotypes a lot of the most pernicious
sort of avenues of bias in the in the
culture so if you think for so the
example I've raised about
um about the donations
this is a place where I think a lot of
people can see that we live in a society
where there are stereotypes for example
about people living in poverty right
right that actually what they're doing
is taking your taxpayer dollars and
using them to avoid entering the
workforce
those kinds of stereotypes
are leveraged to basically reduce
solidarity I would say right to sort of
like to come between people who want to
do the compassionate thing and the
compassionate or the sensible or the
Humane or however you want to describe
it to come between them in that instinct
and sort of create Rifts between people
and it does seem to follow from that
belief that if you believe that you
would say well by donating the cans
rather than the money I am acting
logically based on this stereotype about
the group that would receive it
people to whom you are donating Goods or
money right
the more you'll go out of your way to
only make a very particular kind of
donation
um and I mean and I would sort of still
argue that's a that is still sort of at
its core an inefficient donation
um in part because
it there's not actually I mean in part
because the The Stereotype content is
we don't have reason to believe it's
true right I think it's you know it's
it's bringing in a bunch of sort of
pernicious classism basically when we
think about different types of so you
know there's like hustles scams Ponzi
schemes business practices to some
degree you know we were recently talking
about the FTC now is looking at passing
a law that says you have to be able to
cancel a gym membership in the same way
that you sign up for it right so it
can't be you sign up in 30 seconds
online but then you've got to go in in
person with a notarized form in order to
cancel it if that's how you have to
cancel it then you've got to sign up
that way which would never happen
because the whole point is reduce
friction for the sign up increase
fiction for for the cancellation that's
like a business practice which you can
argue is a sort of hustle or scam but
people's sort of uh uh resistance to it
is very different than someone on the
street asking for money what's happening
psychologically there
yeah it's a great question I so and I
should say that the gym example is like
very close to my heart in part because
my you know day job on teaching
contracts and so I do a lot of my
research about consumer contracts and
the way people interact with this whole
world of sort of clicking to clicking to
to agree yeah and one of my deep
concerns about the way that consumer
contracts operate in the world is that
people do feel like they are bound to
these deals and sort of don't perceive
them as these as exploitation in the way
that you might expect given how hard it
is to get out of your gym membership
right that's right that kind of thing um
so so part of the argument that I'm that
um that you're picking up on is the
argument that
it feels worse to be taken advantage of
by someone who you thought was your
subordinate or peer than someone who you
already assumed had a bunch of power so
if you think that a scam is a power play
and I think it is I think I think
there's a lot about it's about power in
part right when if you feel like you've
been scammed one of the experiences you
have is a feeling is a feeling sort of
foolish and humiliated right it's sort
of a low stat it's a it's a lowering of
your sense of like
what my belonging in this group my sense
of dignity and belonging right okay
being able to be made to feel that way
by someone who you already assumed had
power or or you feel I should say you
feel less if you feel as acutely if it's
coming from someone who you already
thought was sort of making the world go
around
whereas if you think about as people who
you thought were
um who you assumed were sort of in
positions of less power than you and it
feels like you've been kicked down
further on the sort of social ladder in
ways that feel really terrible right in
ways that feel like destabilizing like
what is my sense of status and belonging
in the in this community that's
interesting and and that you know when I
think about
35 overdraft fees on a checking account
which might add up to 500 bucks versus
someone suckered you out of 500 worth of
bitcoin the latter is sort of a someone
just like you who figured out a way to
get 500 in Bitcoin from you versus
something that seems more systematic and
sort of like a business oriented
transaction where you could argue I mean
I'm not saying that you're told the
overdraft fees up front like I
understand that it's not exactly the
same but the feeling would come away
being dramatically different yeah I
think that's right I think people feel
like there's a there's a theory in
Psychology that like that I like a lot
called
um um system justification and it's just
the idea basically is people are sort of
motivated to explain that the system
works right so you're motivated to say
like well you know the banks have to
make their money somehow and I did I
knew you know I was alerted beforehand I
was gonna hit his overdraft fee even
though so even though just to be clear
my own my argument is like no that's
deeply problematic like in fact nobody
can read all these terms and conditions
it's right this is having all of these
sort of fines and fees be associated
with this sort of culture of scolding
people about reading the fine print I
think is super cynical yeah
but I think you're right that when it
comes from like as you say like a peer
like someone who's sort of like
leveraged their position to get one over
on you even though you're both just
people out there in the crypto world if
it feels like yeah I've been like I sort
of have been like demoted in this social
World last thing I want to ask you about
in terms of like foolproofing ourselves
so that we can't be scammed in specific
areas you can always find Tips when it
comes to those phishing emails here's
the way that you handle that when you go
to buy a car don't let them make the
conversation about your monthly payment
like first talk about the sale price
then deal with fine you know there's
within specific areas there's all these
ideas are there more overarching
principles or are they really the types
of principles that lend themselves to
paranoia and are less useful practically
speaking
yeah
you know in some ways I have like this
this deeply unsatisfying answer to that
question which is kind of like that part
of the view of the part of my view is is
to
surrender more often to let it be that
in that there are more cases in which
you have thought through what were the
consequences in this case be of of being
sort of a little bit duped or scammed or
whatever
and if they aren't that big to just let
it go right I think the the context that
you're describing like buying a car
that's exactly the kind of context where
you want to be really have your antennae
up right you want to be like especially
wary the stakes are certainly higher
hi and you know the only goal is to get
out of there with a car that you can
afford it's not like you you don't have
a goal of like making friends with a
salesperson right but there are all
these other contexts in life where you
can sort of get this kind of Sucker
prickle at the back you know like like
oh is this gonna happen to me that
happened I mean so for example in the
life of a teacher that's me right in the
in your life as a parent as a friend
where you start to get that that little
prickle and it really helps to think
well wait a minute what actually is the
risk here how big of a deal would it be
if I gave a student an extension on a
paper but they didn't technically need
for the reason they said that they
needed right that would probably be to
be a small deal by contrast it would
feel like a really big deal if I treated
a student callously who actually needed
my help right right it's about like
weighing the real risks and sort of
going back to that investment example
right of like asking yourself to talk
through the math a little bit to say is
it right do I really think that that my
sort of focus on this you know risk of a
fraudster is something that I believe in
in some deeper way or is this a little
mistake I'm making a sort of a way my
attention's been
been torn away from the place where it
really belongs yeah and the example
about the paper and the extension also
relates to an asymmetry in if I'm
correctly assessing versus incorrectly
assessing and that that certainly can be
a big factor as well the book is
foolproof how fear of playing the sucker
shapes ourselves and the social order
and what we can do about it we've been
speaking with the book's author
Professor Tess Wilkinson Ryan really
appreciate your time and your insights
today
this was great